that was a real celebration what did  that moment feel like to you oh my gosh  everything in my life that has happened  from the minute I was born led me to  this point so I just feel like wow I'm  exactly where I'm supposed to be I'm  only 21 years old and I'm at the Grammys  I watched the cutest video of you as a  little girl playing a bunch of  instruments in your house and you talked  about getting to a moment like this and  now that it happens do you feel the  power my gosh I mean a little bit I  don't know it's surreal still but it  just it kind of hit me just then that  moment right there just looking at all  the faces in the crowd I'm trying to  prove to people why I deserve to be  nominated for for five Grammys and I  feel like I have to prove it to myself  why I deserve to be here  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]